ce que vous avez dit chez jean marc
morandini donc vous pouvez leur dire
aujourd'hui vous allez vous allez sortir
vous écoutez c'est très simple je vais
voulu prendre je vais sortir et je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi ce qu'il faut
pas simplement faire le buzz
il faut regarder toujours les documents
c'est ça lors du 2ème confinement moi
j'ai lu tous les jours les documents
officiels et les communiqués de presse
ils sont assez rébarbatif mais il faut
les lire de santé publique je pense qu
est-ce qui disait il disait qu premiers
froids quand les gens se sont re
confinés chez eux
les premiers transports en commun ils
travaillaient ils sont sont confinés
chez eux qui ont été les clusters ou
honte et les foyers de copies de
contamination dans les familles
parce que dès qu'il fait froid dès que
l'hiver arrive on est dans les familles
on se confine alors que la journée on
vaque à ses occupations
c'est ça la vérité donc premièrement
deuxièmement j'ai pas envie moi je fais
beaucoup de reportages dans la france
profonde comme on dit je vois des
étudiants qui sont au bord du suicide ce
à en parler dans ces incidents
je vois des restaurateurs je vois des
commerçants je vois des gens qui sont
exemple qui sont à bout de forces qui
sont à bout de nerfs qu'à l'horizon on
leur propose autre effet collatéral
je parle avec beaucoup de médecins comme
sans doute beaucoup d'entre vous tous
les toutes les autres pathologies les
cancers qu'on arrivait à détecter et
c'est on le fait plus aujourd'hui où il
ya des nouveaux des cancer en phase
terminale
c'est un vrai scandale les désastres
psychologiques la détresse des gens on
est en train d'être complètement
zombifiés mis sous cloche
est ce qu'on a envie de ça pour notre
avenir je finis là dessus un autre effet
collatéral la violence faite aux femmes
les viols qui ont explosé bien sûr les
violences familiales
mais didier qu'est ce qu'on fait on va
faire des misères au madiran se
confirmer vous avez le remède et vous
savez que j'étais un grand vous êtes un
grand patron de média ou tel était un
voilà vous me comprenez bien que les
gens ce qui vous reprochent moi je me
fais le porte parole de ce que je vois
sur les réseaux quand vous appelez à la
réunion il ya plein de gens qui lisent
vous avez une voix qui porte vous avez
un discours qui intéresse beaucoup de
monde et qui peut influencer beaucoup de
monde quand vous appelez à dire aux gens
quand vous dites moi d'arrêter le
confinement il ya plein de gens qui vont
dire pourquoi didier maïsto lf et puis
savait et et donc il neigera en terre
gelée gens n'ont pas besoin de moi c'est
un complément
j'ai simplement obligé
si vous le faites allant au bout mais
parce que j'ai eus objective et un
ressenti très profond très répandu dans
la société française nicolas pernikoff
vous n'avez pas l'air d'accord avec je
fais tout d'accord alors j'aime beaucoup
didier parce qu'il ya des combats je
respecte que vous menez et gégé respecte
là je vous comprends pas je vous le dit
soit vous êtes en campagne politique
parce que ce que vous êtes en train
d'essayer de vous n'êtes même pas en
train de dire parce que je vous
écouterai si vous dites je dénonce
toutes les incohérences ok gad elmaleh
faisait a dit des choses d'ailleurs sur
les avions il a raison sera gratuit
nation un avion qu'on aura les
attaquants soient cohérents les emplois
dans les connaît toutes les et
aujourd'hui le seul moyen
le seul moyen de freiner cette épidémie
c'est le fameux stop and go dont vous
parlez c'est à dire qu'on sait bien que
il y aurait dû y avoir un travail de
l'état je pense sur le fait d'augmenter
les lie parce que on est toujours à cinq
ou six mille lits de réanimation
on devrait en avoir dix huit ou vingt
mille aujourd'hui donc on ne l'a pas
anticipé je suis aussi d'accord avec
vous mais aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas
l'homme que vous êtes ne peut pas
appeler alors à désobéir et ses volets
gazon ça c'est une objection comme
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je termine toulousains
pointent aujourd'hui les plus grands que
sont out ou d'autres je suis désolé moi
je respecte
raul qui est un grand acquis le réanimer
en tout cas c'est un grand monsieur
on serait à 200 ou 300 mille morts ou
d'autres si on dit qu'on n'avait pas
confiné exactement comme ça aujourd'hui
lui même est en train et même un
résidant à oran à 10400 mis le mot
japonais d'alors un million on n'en sait
rien et la solution sais rien mais je
voulais passer plateau vous êtes vous
êtes quelqu'un d'autre que ça même pas
se baigner sur un plateau pour proposer
une solution alors vous l'importez alors
je alors la solution je vous l'apprends
pas de solution c'est quoi la solution
le remède là pour l'instant est pire que
le mal parce que sur didier je voudrais
juste dire un truc avant que vous
proposez votre solution
vous avez vu que dans le monde entier on
trouve pas la solution doc là vous avez
raté la le monde entier nous regarde
la solution il dit il faut toujours
alors puisqu'on parle de médecine les
médecins vous diront tous et le
professeur out avec qui on a souvent
échangé il faut soigner il faut faire le
ratio bénéfice risque au bout d'un an
quand le ratio bénéfice risque penche
plus du côté du risque on a le droit
elle saurait expliquer pose est ce que
vous dites là voilà donc il faut la
vente il ya une balance
il ya des avantages et des inconvénients
là parce que ce que vous êtes en train
de dire didier si je comprends bien
si vous dites le risque de mort il est
faible 2 et les voilà il y les deux sens
est-ce qu'on va prendre
est-ce qu'on va re confiné tout un pays
est-ce qu'on va prendre des mesures qui
vont faire qu économiquement le pays
avoir beaucoup de mal à s'en remettre et
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens aussi qui vont
être dans une détresse dans une
précarité dans une dans une détresse
psychologique incroyable pour un nombre
de morts qui n'est pour vous pas assez
important c'est ce que vous êtes donc en
dire je ne dis pas comme ça mais si on
va dans ce sujet là on va donner
quelques chiffres je n'aime pas beaucoup
les chiffres mais là ces signifiants
l'espérance de vie en france pour les
hommes elle est de 79 5
oui pour les femmes 85 et 83 non 85 et
dernier média auquel on décède du coc
vide ses 85 ans oui avec 65% de facteurs
de comorbidité être technique ça veut
dire des maladies cardiovasculaires et
quand on arrive à 85 ans moi j'ai un
père qui a 87 ans une mère cac 79 ans on
a des pattes aux avait peur pour eux
mais bien sûr que j'ai peur je suis quoi
un robot non mais c'est sûr donc
j'essaie d'être raisonnable et je me
prive d'aller les voir comme beaucoup de
français